[Music]  [Music]  okay so first off i just want to say  i get it  you get what  high school  kamala kamala another adventure shirt  cute she thinks i'm some kind of weirdo  you are weirdo boys excuse me yeah  you're kind of on my shirt sorry  but you're staring at the window in your  little fantasy land  come on hey already really come on like  do i have to figure out my whole future  before launchers  [Music]  maybe they're right  i spend too much time  in fantasyland  that is not you  it's not really the brown girls from  jersey city  you save the world  that's a fantasy too  did something happen to you no why did  you hear something come on  what does it feel like  cosmic  i always thought i wanted this kind of  life  [Music]  but i never imagined any of  do  this  even know what you are  i'm a superhero  [Music]  [Music]  you